منافسه المحتدمه تلوح في الافق داخل الحزب
الجمهوري مواجهه سيكون طرفاها رئيس
الجمهوري السابق دونالد ترامب وحاكم ولايه
فلوريد
فصديق الامس يتحول رسميا الى خصم لدود
ينافس على بطاقه الترشح داخل الحزب خبر
ترشيح ليس بالمفاجئ فاحتماليه ترشيحه لا
حتى في الافق منذ مده ليست بالقصيره لكن
اللافت في الموضوع هو طريقه الاعلان عن
هذا الترشح والتي ستتم لاول مره عبر منصه
تويتر خلال حوار مع مالك المنصه ايلون
ماسك
لسانتس نجح ايضا في لفت الانتباه من خلال
الطريقه اختارها للاعلان عن ترشحه ليكون
اعلانا غير مسبوق يحدث للمره الاولى على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وسيجري ماسك
مقابله مع ليسانس على تويتر سبيسز وهي
منصه للمحادثات الصوتيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات